watching that trailer I gotta tell you
Matt I was like really enthused but I
was watching it it's maybe because I
don't know the medications I took
earlier or if it's because of the fact
that the trailer actually does look bomb
oh my god watching the trailer going oh
this this looks like a big you like step
up if the trailer is portraying the film
properly this looks like a step up from
the last Ninja Turtles the optimist in
me is thinking to myself it looks as
though they actually made a movie in the
spirit they actually embraced the spirit
of the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and
the cartoons and the old Lee and stuff
and just decided to take all their
resources and honor that spirit it looks
like it it might have a soul
exactly it could easily not have a soul
like you know cuz it's still I felt like
they were really going for like a darker
Ninja Turtles which I don't I haven't
read the comics of it I've seen the
cartoons and the previous live action
movies and TMNT pretty good like the
first movie the first injured Turtles
movie kind of has like half a soul cuz
like the Ninja Turtles are really good
cuz like their chemistry actually kind
of was surprising and nice and then
turtles we talked about the last one the
first remark that are talking about the
one from no no no the one that Joey was
rendered like don't you know being that
this is a sequel to that movie that
movie felt kinda like it had half of a
soul because it got the Ninja Turtles
right and that was cool like it's a good
thing to get right but it got a lot of
other stuff like wrong or creepy or like
choppy and stuff yeah it only felt like
Michael Bay movies have this thing where
they have kind of a bro II like this is
cool and well-made but kind of soulless
you know and this movie looks as though
it's actually having fun and like you
know like you said there's like a good
message in there about keeping the team
together which is a little more nuanced
than just like you know absolute power
does any of this make sense okay um
create observations okay got to point
out the good first they say point out
three good things don't that you spoke
more confident than usual and I feel
that yeah just naturally your confidence
is there however I notice most of the
time you worried I mean I'm gonna hang
it up in camera that's real bothersome
thing for B sub documents this is so
funny to me one thing I absolutely love
from this trailer for sure
I [ __ ] love the fact that we got like
a real shredder going on you know it's
not like I noticed an improvement of
quality and the visuals alone
I think the cinematography looks a lot
better well it just likes legion ass I
yeah I can't share it I was bored
you say he's a good DP that I was like
don't make a double penetration joke why
I think it's like now my singing is Ryan
fighting his way back into your time you
know that make sex jokes some time back
if you're not gonna rip open there will
just be like TV snow inside like a David
Lynch movie the visuals do look better
they look sharper they don't just look
as dark you know like I felt like the
first one I know like yeah and the water
weights it's also meant for kids however
I'm like it's still kind of a visually
dark looking movie well because like the
the violent stuff especially the stuff
with shredder it has an intensity and it
feels really personal and like yeah like
they bother to make that gritty and make
it look like it really hurts
this one doesn't feel like
sinister-looking to me yeah there's one
felt like it could be fun but it also
looks sinister like yeah that's a
problem the darkness tone a chest in an
alleyway you're just like that could be
cool look like that the look doesn't
make it go oh it's not dark at all like
the film certainly still has this cool
dark imagery but but this one looks like
it's embracing the spirit and embracing
you know being a car
- yeah just like with big blockbuster
scale tools to make it you know yeah
it's embracing what it actually is you
know that's kind of why I do feel like a
fast and furious why because it was like
you guys to get you there way too
seriously at first this time around
we're gonna have a lot fun well in this
it seems like you know because because
to make us take these movies more
seriously in the recent time they've
made them a really dark itself serious
and they're finally realizing like oh
maybe people just kind of want to have a
good time yeah if that's in the scenario
they change directors yeah so I'm sure
like this guy had a like this could have
a soul
like this one could take that surrender
screw you know what we can make this big
and crazy and also fun and this can
easily go wrong like still like I'm not
I'm not like fully embracing it but it
does look go I think what we would want
yeah exactly
oh you brought in some of the more
whimsical villains to like bebop and
Rocksteady are in there which are bebop
and Rocksteady
yeah and wouldn't saw the first one I
kind of got the sense that you really
have but it looks like you that's what I
mean like yeah it there is a certain
different visual layout that allows for
this tone in energy yeah is if if if the
visual layout looked exactly like the
first like even Splinter I was looking
at sweater for the brief moments we got
it I was like splitter it doesn't look
as creepy you know oh yeah it's like
they're embracing the magic like yeah
I'm racing the magic that this can have
to it you know and and being greedy when
they fight exactly we can the beginning
parts of the trailer we see how like you
know the destruction and all that how
that's gonna look but it totally looks
like out of a Michael Bay flick or out
of any summer blockbuster flick with you
know New York being destroyed and stuff
that wasn't what I walked away from with
this trailer was they were trying to
show all that it's mainly like it's it's
fun its stylized I think visuals of like
even the Turtles I think look better
live rotted bebop and rocksteady like
they've refined the the the way their
word universe works so that those Harbor
rocks that did its bulk and skull
stop what are you doing are you doing
that no that's my power I can make you
feel like an idiot I remember watching
the cartoons really loving them and I
really feel like they're capturing the
personality of them well like who were
the voices of them I'm even too big
bebop Jerry Anthony Williams do not be
huge here Anthony Williams man he's my
favorite hey Ally man plays a model
sweet and Steven fairly Oh Farley barely
barely oh dude yeah it like he's
rissalah uh he is like I'm a huge
wrestling fan like Tyrone madness if you
guys are magnetized I guarantee you I
will not disappoint you I have my
awesome you know knowledge of the WWE
he's really telling I'm so into that
very much about it Stefan Amell that's
how I call him well my father's name was
Stefan and the pH so he might even say
Steven to make it easier on everyone but
Stefan is the proper name to pronounce
the name when there's a pH there just so
you all know but I haven't seen all of
arrow I believe like seeing a little bit
of the first season uh there's a lot of
shows I gotta get through okay I'm sorry
I've seen a little bit of the first
season and the number one thing I think
of is the you know Stefan mm like he is
awesome he's great
freakin League like I'm totally on board
when he is like on screen I love the guy
please you haven't seen arrow man this
sounds like you've like laid awake
nights thinking about how arrow is not a
comedy but the guy can do humor very
well and that's a perfect actor that you
would need to be Casey I mean one thing
that I'm kind of a little thrown off by
is like
you know I always imagined Casey to be a
little bit grittier looking and stuff
Oh Stefan to melody only thing I'm super
he still looks like all over quickie I
mean you know that could be cool I
haven't seen his work yeah yeah so shut
ur piehole before I make you poop out of
the penis of your hole I think it's
really gonna have it I like that they
change of directors who's the idea
record is Dave green Oh huge fan of
daydreams films seen them all earth to
echo earth to echo but but it does seem
like it was a more broadly like family
accessible I think if they're thinking
in that direction
cool that almost seems like it would be
a nice thing to do with the Ninja
Turtles I'm not even listening
there was this one shot in the trailer
I'm pulling it up right now I mean it
could be Craig something about the front
of him but it certainly I would guess
that is him yeah maybe I mean like I
wouldn't be surprised like it's hard to
like it's intentionally we need to do is
take a screenshot of this send it to
collider.com and we gotta get common box
is going you know I'm gonna get this
smell right this could be the one they
make another the Martian about comedy of
the year when we saw the first one ever
can they really bring if those three
characters into this and this movie goes
yeah we'll make some adjustments and
make that happen and what that makes me
wonder is just what's the stuff from the
last movie gonna figure into this cuz we
saw like Will Arnett and April O'Neil
and shredder for like a second and they
really played up the new stuff so I
don't know how they're gonna figure in
and that's what I'm wondering you know
if that'll you know grow with it as well
or not it's a good point shut up yeah I
got the point
owner if they did okay everything looks
solid about it to me like eat the
turtles look cool and fun again I like
that they have their there
van like that's the it's the turtle van
like that's back baby
we're there to go Vegas baby you know
I'm talking about honey there quote
finally giving the fans what they want
you know yeah yeah and and and that
could be really cool thing
why are you like so passionate about
like the first one not being so great no
it's not that big like finally giving
the fans what they want well not only
you know fans were okay with it you know
people were like VBS is one of the best
films I've ever seen in my entire life
oh gee that's also not the case but no
that's what everyone feels and things me
and Fox you know she looks you know
still hot and that's good yes that's
what I really care to see when I watch
Megan Fox okay some people might be like
douche move I'm like who the [ __ ] is now
going into a film going see it Megan Fox
nails at this time well know as though
it's like hey hey I'm not done you
jackass mr. interrupter I've seen Megan
Fox insert roles where I'm like she's
okay she's fine
yeah at the end of the day though what I
really care about is are we gonna see
some sexy shots somebody box if she's in
there I kind of want to see I don't know
what to talk about I actually want to
see her yeah I believe anyone is capable
if they're confident enough to be in
front of the camera like that if they
just you know like find a way to be more
authentic in some way whatever process I
totally feel like Megan Fox can do it
well yeah he's a video supporting Megan
Fox in the first movie it's a weird
character the way they drive but like
Megan Fox is taking this [ __ ]
seriously like she's really putting it
putting in the work and so this one it
looks like they could make her like more
fun or more like you know well in the
first person
yeah get you
okay most importantly the number one
thing on self before Tyler Perry looks
like he is doing a cartoony fun roll I
just want this one to be a fun awesome
action adventure flick I hope they get
that right yeah but if they don't I'm
telling you like if they don't get it
right I would be upset I know but it's
produced from like the best director of
all time Michael Bay everyone can agree
on that too right
I felt like they had a fun script and
then they were like we got dark in this
cuz everything's dark you know so I feel
like they're gonna find a better total
match in this maybe they learn from Fast
and the Furious and that's a smart idea
exactly acknowledge what you are just
own yourself and be genuine and have fun
or they acknowledge with Zack Snyder did
which is and and what Michael Bay does
you know you hear the complaints and you
go no if I show you more of it you will
understand it if you're new to this
channel [ __ ] it
subscribe has reasons the jetty and dig
s Stubbs why are you judging
everything's are and you can follow us
on social networks and I pray that
Robert DeNiro maintains a healthy life
and continues to you know attract many a
black woman into his life he likes black
woman it's a fact it's not a joke it's a
fact it's a real fact if you know
anything about Rama De Niro's personal
life he likes black boxes